how many hours do you think that you
have obsessed over the game of chess
that's a tough question how many games
could you play at one time whether
online or in person it's easy you can
play maybe you want to tell them do you
share tips and tricks and secrets with
other top players or is it very kind of
taboo
you obviously are ukrainian how do you
think about the russian invasion of
ukraine and as you speak to people in
ukraine what are they telling you about
the actual situation on the ground to
say it's heartbreaking for me to see
what happens that's the least i can say
all right guys bang bang uh i'm very
much looking for this conversation uh
not every day that i get to talk to a
chess grandmaster and i thought a great
place to start is how many hours do you
think that you have obsessed over the
game of chess to actually reach the
level uh of expertise that you now have
well that's a tough question uh really
i've never counted those hours uh you
know maybe i will go a little sidewise i
played tennis a little but i was so bad
in middles but i just remember that my
coach he said that to master the game
you probably need to make one million uh
hits
and uh
and that's just you know a round number
just to say like okay hey you you can
claim that you you know how to play
tennis if you made 1 million kills but
in chess it's really difficult to say
how much time it takes for a person to
to become a grandmaster i
in years wise well it took me
since i began when i was eight and i i
became a grandmaster when i was uh 22.
so you can have like 14 years yeah how
many hours do you think you were playing
per day between like ages like 8 and 15.
so kind of when you were younger and you
didn't have lots of other life
responsibilities like how many hours
would you play
well uh
not many to be honest so for me it took
like maybe like two three hours a day
and that was sufficiently enough
i would say that the
more important here is is intensity with
which you you do this so it's it's not
about like regularly training but but
rather to successfully play in the
tournaments to constantly improve
yourself and uh
in terms of chess it's really
maybe unique sport and sense that you
you really don't need to practice it
every day to to keep up the form uh it's
pretty much okay not to play let's say
for three months and then quickly pick
up the game in
a couple of days
yeah how much better are grand masters
than like the top players right so for
the people who actually are a
grandmaster versus everyone else is it a
an analogy that you could use to explain
to people just how much better at chess
you are than the average player
also there is there's no unique
measurement you know so it's
really difficult to compare but but but
you know the difference is is obvious if
you if you put a grand master and
versus someone a random player uh
definitely we would see the difference
in how the game evolves and uh
uh probably it's again it's easier to
make a comparison with some uh
spectacular sports like uh
let's pick tennis again so when you see
like how federer plays right or nadal or
djokovic uh
definitely their level is is way better
even than you know many professionals so
let's say uh
well
also
it's difficult to to compare because in
tennis you don't see those top guys
encounter uh uh amateurs right so you
don't see this often in chair cities it
is way more common because in any
regular tournament in open tournaments
where you have like around 600 players
it can be the situation that you have
let's say like 10 20 grand masters and
uh pretty much everybody else ranging
from from the beginners to to people of
international master level uh people who
are experienced players who played let's
say 10 20 years 30
um
but really the
the differences is really subtle from
from the outsider point of view so if
you never watch chess
uh for you it would be difficult to say
like why why the guy is the grandmaster
why he plays uh better
but but yeah probably
it's it's something that you you would
experience once you see it
maybe i just can recall
a recent uh
like kind of exhibition games just
friendly games with my uh teammates from
work and they
uh
they really were amazed and i was
humbled humbled to to to hear a lot of
saying that yeah it's really amazing to
see how you play chess because our
thought process is very different from
from what we see how you play because
they just see that for me it's
effortlessly to to to you know make a
good move and uh for them when they just
don't understand how it happens that
fast and the answer is pretty simple
right because once you you've played it
for many many years it's it's quite easy
for you to to do it right so just
imagine like let's say you you you learn
some new language and for you it would
take some time even to uh
to memorize some word right and then it
takes some you know time to to recall
them but for a person who speaks you
know this language for all their lives
it's quite easy
so one of the pieces that i i've always
wondered is like for our grand master
how much of it is uh memorization of
opening moves and kind of a lot of the
the muscle memory just comes from i've
played so many games i've seen this
already i know how to handle that
situation versus no actually there is a
kind of a new computation that is
occurring every single time you're
playing a game well luckily it's both
so definitely memorization it takes a
lot of part in professional chess and
also in amateur chess especially
nowadays when computers are extremely
strong and the theory of openings it
evolved tremendously
i would say like over the past like 10
20 years where computer
when computers became really strong
that's why in professional chess
definitely memorization it's it's a very
big part of the battle but luckily it's
it's not all so you cannot win just by
memorizing the lines because definitely
at some point of the game uh it turns
the point where you need to uh to work
yourself and if you don't have the
necessary skills that you don't have uh
experience and understanding of what to
do in the position then
it wouldn't work and uh again luckily uh
in chess those occasions they're they're
pretty much in every game so your
preparation for the game
of course it takes a lot of hours
because you need to memorize a lot of
stuff you need
you normally try to predict what your
opponent would do and uh
you just try to memorize the lines that
you've already seen probably or or you
try to prepare something new that you've
never played but for this specific
opponent you need to
uh come up with something new
but
nevertheless like once you get into the
game and you begin playing by your plan
then you see like suddenly your opponent
just changes his mind or probably they
just decided to play something that you
you just didn't take into account and
then you need to to begin your own
thought process and uh
that's why uh luckily it just
accommodates both styles so there are
players who uh really they don't
memorize anything so they they just play
by intuition and they prefer to uh
try to avoid
their opponents preparations and that
that's also sufficiently fine for a
parameter just but of course for in the
professional world if we talk about like
uh top guys uh it wouldn't work so you
you need to combine both you need to be
uh
with memory like psychologically also
emotionally you need to be a really good
chess player in
in many many ways
how how much of the game in person is uh
psychological like can you psych out
your uh opponent not necessarily with
the moves on the actual board but are
there things that you see in competition
where uh there's almost a game off of
the board that's happening
oh yeah certainly it's it's always there
and
just as extremely psychological game and
of course uh if we talk about pandemic
and the online chess that became popular
over the past few years uh things
changed a little because
when you sit over the board and you see
your opponent
i see you know her his face and you
understand that uh uh what kind of
thoughts are
inside of the person and uh that really
helps you in some way so you can be
aggressive in terms of some moves
actually like yeah you asked about like
uh move wise or not move wise actually
uh over the board it also makes sense
sometimes you you can vlog you can do
not really the best move but the move
that would be the most unpleasant for
your opponent or maybe unexpected um
like off the board the it also matters
but
ultimately i would say just personally
on my feeling for my career it didn't
matter that much
because also chess players they like to
focus on on the game and on the essence
and on the board rather than try to
outplay opponents off the board yeah how
many games could you play at one time
whether online or in person is there
like a number that you feel really
comfortable four games eight games 12
games like how do you think about that
uh
well i i've played simuls in my career
of course and uh over the board i think
it was like 25
kids
who whom i played at once
which is which is reasonable number i i
definitely i i'm not sure there is a
limit so i i i i think i would easily
play like 50 100 it doesn't really
matter what matters is is timing and
those kind of things are and of course
the level of the opponents it matters a
lot because when you play like uh kids
who just began playing uh then it's it's
it's easy you can play maybe even a
thousand games but uh i played yeah i
played kids who were
so they've played already you know three
four five years and uh they're quite
tough to beat but uh still i managed i
remember this time
i managed to beat all of them and
normally in simuls that that's how i do
i just you know beat everyone and i'm
merciless in this sense because uh
i think that you know you learn a lot in
from from those times i also remember
myself as a kid and i played those
simulsam uh against grandmasters and uh
i enjoyed them a lot though i also lost
myself but
that's my approach that one once you
lose you you can learn from your
mistakes and that's that's the biggest
source of your improvement uh online
wise
i think i played like around 20 20
boards and uh
20 games and uh that's that's also just
just adequate number and
i think it just depends on the number of
people who would like to encounter you
in the game yeah it sounds insane when
you say that you could play 100 uh
simultaneous games uh but to your point
if you're simply just concentrating on
the board that you're looking at in that
moment uh and you're playing somebody
who has lesser skill than you uh then
there's advantages that you obviously
get are there certain things outside of
just playing chess uh for hours you know
per day that you could attribute to
actually getting better and eventually
reaching grand master
oh absolutely actually uh playing is not
the the only source
mostly it's reading books
chess literature is extremely prolific
without uh you know some say that
actually chess literature is the biggest
among any kind of literature which which
is difficult to uh
really comprehend i i mean
in sense of let's say science so books
and physics if you count the total books
that you know the humanity produced over
the years
it would be surprising to to discover
that actually chess books are uh way
more by
by the by the numbers by the just rough
uh account of how many books were
produced uh so really there's a lot of
literature and uh
of course uh to that uh training camps
uh
it's extremely important to have coaches
uh people who would tell you like what
you're doing right what you're doing
wrong on uh every stage of your career
and even uh professional guys they they
do have coaches though like let's say we
talk about the very best the world
champion magnus carlson he has a lot of
people who who helped him who helped him
in preparation and psychology and many
other aspects so it's literally like as
in any other sport you see that you see
a professional player playing but at the
same time behind the scenes there are
just enormous team of people who support
this
performance
do you share tips and tricks and secrets
with other top players or is it very
kind of taboo and uh if you're a good
chess player you don't want others to
know uh to know all your secrets
uh to some extent
of course uh
you you know if you follow chess you you
would immediately see that normally
chess players they don't want to
elaborate a lot on their preparation and
say like hey okay this is something that
that was prepared long time ago or this
was my full thought process during the
game uh normally we see other there are
interviews and commentaries after the
game where
you know when players they share their
thoughts but they do not sincere 100
that's that's that's for sure
and of course there are some
tips and tricks that every chess player
uses
uh and uh
normally yeah it's it's something that
we just get used to we do not share it
unless uh with our teammates and our
coaches for example if it's a team
competition definitely we can uh
exchange of ideas
let's say to play against some opponents
what are their weaknesses and those kind
of things
or uh in terms of opening preparation
that's that's also important to
to kind of discuss it in teams
definitely it's it's you know the famous
proverb that one head is good but you
know two cats are always better
when i think about chess today um i
would put myself very much in the
amateur category but i'm fascinated by
uh aspects of the game including uh uh
kind of machines uh i'm interested in
the kind of global nature of the game
and how chess uh people who have
mastered the game of chess think outside
of uh chess itself and kind of what it
teaches you from a a kind of logic
standpoint if we think of machines two
of the areas that i find absolutely
fascinating is one the rise of
artificial intelligence or machine
learning uh and so now we have humans
competing against computers and if you
know somebody has a mobile app on their
phone and they're playing against kind
of a low-grade computer if you're good
at chess you can pretty much set the
difficulty level you can beat it over
and over and over again but what i've
started to see now is that there are a
number of models or machines that are
defeating grandmasters and and people
who are very very good at chess and so
how do you think about this introduction
of kind of more sophisticated uh
computers into the game of chess is it
good is it bad do you seek them out to
play them do you get frustrated like how
do you think about it this episode is
brought to you by athletic greens i
drink ag-1 by athletic greens every
single day i started it out a couple of
years ago and i liked it so much that i
even became an investor in the business
every single day rather than take a
bunch of pills for vitamins and minerals
i simply take one scoop of ag-1 in a
glass of water it gives me 75 vitamins
minerals probiotics superfoods and
adaptogens i really really like it
because it's so simple if you go and you
sign up at
athleticgreens.com today they will give
you one year of immune supporting
vitamin d for free and they will also
give you five free travel packages go to
athleticgreens.com
today to get started stop taking all
those vitamin and mineral pills and just
take one scoop of ag1
athleticgreens.com go check them out
today
well i frankly have mixed feelings
because you know i i have my phone and
it well i'm not sure if you can see it
but but but anyway it's uh
it's really awful feeling when you you
just cannot beat your phone
and uh and actually i i was lucky that i
i raised that
at the times were when computers were
not that strong and uh
back in that days uh we didn't even have
smartphones so there was no even
question whether you can beat a cell
phone or not
uh there was a famous story when uh gary
casper was first
bit by a machine back in the end of 90s
he lost the deep blue and it was quite a
big deal at that time because
arguably it was a turning point in chess
history when
a machine
really beat
human now of course uh we see a
tremendous progress of
computers and of course uh
machine learning techniques involved in
that it's it's really something amazing
when uh alpha zero which is uh arguably
also the the best uh
just engine uh
ever uh based on you know machine
learning uh
algorithms one once it
kind of
released i i really couldn't believe you
it
it happens because i thought it's some
kind of fake or scam because
uh
the performance of uh
zero was so much better than traditional
engines that would have on chess
that really also it was kind of a
revolution in the game but
nowadays indeed uh
we as
human humans we just cannot compete with
with computers it's it's like literally
like trying to run a 100 meter race
against uh against the supercar
uh because the computational abilities
of computers these days uh they're
enormous and also
the algorithms of evolution of positions
and uh
how to approach chess it's it's very
different in terms of technologies uh
these days that's why uh computer
preparation uh nowadays
it is it weighs way more than it was
let's say 10 years 15 years ago and not
saying like 25 years ago or maybe like
let's say let's see if we talk about
before computer era 50 70 years ago
which arguably was also golden era of
just one people really they uh uh
kind of competed over the board now we
we definitely can say that modern chess
players that they not only compete over
the board but they also compete in their
home labs when they have a lot of
assistance they have a lot of computers
uh various approaches to
to
to positions to openings and uh
there is also a question who has the
strongest computer
uh though again as i already mentioned
luckily uh it's the question who is a
better chess player luckily it's not
only about uh who has better home
preparation who has a stronger computer
so still you can uh
you can can beat the guy with with the
you know strongest preparation just by
because you're more talented and that
that that's really cool but just getting
back to your question how how how i
really feel about it and uh how it
really affected the
the the kind of the approach to chess
um
really in in a way it feels bad when you
know you get into trap
you know you know when you just play
with the kid who really just put
everything in the computer back home and
uh you cannot outplay them uh right from
the start just because your preparation
is no longer better because back in the
times uh
you know becoming a grandmaster it takes
to read in a lot of books and you
you're very knowledgeable in in openings
now
there is no such advantage exist
literally anyone can just open their
their
computer would
just engine on and uh
they're going to be experts as you are
so really there's no need to
[Music]
to have access to grandmasters to to get
some sense of the position uh these days
uh computers they suggest literally
better moves and solutions compared to
humans
and that's why it became very different
uh
those still it's
in no way it means that uh chess is
in deep trouble and we were just ending
up seeing computers battling themselves
uh not at all uh still uh we're running
at the same hundred meters but you know
i'm on uh humans not not with super cars
do you think that computers will just
play each other like is there a time
where whether it's tournaments or uh for
just entertainment purposes or whatever
like we'll just see computers competing
against computers and humans will just
be spectators
well actually it's already there
actually you probably were not aware of
this but there are tournaments between
computers and uh there are all these
competitions though you know i myself
also i must confess that i don't follow
them because
it's quite boring when you see a normal
chess especially for me as a
kind of semi-professional chess player
it's really a lot of pleasure to watch
how people play chess but for me there
is little pleasure to see how machines
try to get each other
uh of course i i i occasionally i come
across the games and i see like how they
play and
how they uh
you know approach positions approach uh
ideas but it's really completely
different field and uh
but but there are tournaments and i'm
not sure when they begun but uh i i
would say that they began as long as
just engines
were released so
let's say just if you put some time
stamp begin like beginning of 2000's
that's probably the time when uh those
uh tournaments among chess computers
they began and
they keep on competing in nowadays
that's how we discovered that also
machine learning uh
based uh
computers there they're stronger than
traditional engines but of course
it also requires to
to kind of adjust the computers in terms
of computational power because
apparently if you have uh
more cores if you have uh let's say
uh
as we say like uh yeah
more feral into that then
the computer would be better
when you think about uh the rise of
these chess engines how prevalent is
cheating i'm assuming online there's
lots of quarter quote cheating depending
on how you want to characterize that and
tournaments or whatever but does that
also spill over into kind of physical
tournaments as well in person
tournaments or how do you think about
cheating in in the chess world right now
oh yeah it's actually it's a big topic
it's a big topic and a lot of debates in
the chess world around it because
really there is a great fear of cheating
simply because it became so so easy
and and again it's just as easy as just
just having a phone right so because you
know that the phone plays better than
you and you literally can uh improve
your game just looking at the phone
uh right and that's why cheating it
became
widely available and that's why
also these days in the tournaments it's
it's really a must for the organizers to
like make sure that all the
anti-cheating measures that they're in
place
and uh just just a day ago
it was a huge scandal uh
and it's still a scandal we're kind of
a made of this uh
chess drama as we call it that uh world
champion magnus carlson he uh withdrew
from the tournament which happened the
first time in his career and uh
supposedly it is related to
some suspicions that the guy in the
tournament who
actually beat magnus just a day before
magnus withdrew that he cheated
uh
although there is no any direct evidence
as far as i know and uh
and that's a big problem indeed and that
that's that's a huge debate uh uh what
to do in future because uh
if we admit that it's so easy to cheat
and uh perform way better than than you
are then
yeah difficult to say that we again
compete on the track field uh not
against uh supercars but uh also there
is a problem that
in in a way it became a witch hunt
because
uh also people who apparently they do
not cheat
but they perform uh extremely strong for
for various reasons and then of course
if we talk about young
players it's it's really possible to
gain strength quite quickly as in any
other sport right you see like a 14 year
old kid just doesn't know how to play i
don't know let's say football but then
in two years it's a superstar of
nfl right so that's that's quite common
uh
so in chess it's exactly the same
uh and that's why we see that uh
youngsters they they rise quite fast and
then of course since we know that in our
computer era
uh you know some miracles they might
happen not because you're a talented
player and not because you put a lot of
effort in the game but just simply
because you
found the find on the way to achieve
uh regarding online tournaments it's
even worse because
uh when we play uh back at holes
it's really difficult to uh
prevent people from cheating
uh though of course in professional
chess world
we know that we don't cheat for example
i myself when i play another grand
master in an official tournament let's
say it was uh students league uh
i i know that we don't cheat because
it's kind of also professional ethics we
were raised in completely different
mentality uh
it's just simply not acceptable to
achieve because
also for me like let's say if i talk
about myself personally
it's a really red line so once i begin
cheating it means that i'm not a chess
player anymore because when i play chess
i enjoy uh not only beating the opponent
but i enjoy uh
making the best move and finding it
myself and being proud of myself
performing
well in chess so imagine what i mean
let's say you again look let's be big
tennis right so if you if you play uh
and with rafael nadal then you can be
proud of yourself but would you be
proud in the same way if you cheated
with you if you used
you know some doping or uh
or medicine or
or do something uh
unacceptable it would be completely
different feeling so and
in terms of uh
getting enjoyment from the game it's
it's uh it's really not acceptable to
cross this line
when you think about cheating
a lot of people will talk about the
chess engines what about things that uh
people ingest so you know some people
would argue oh uh you drank coffee i
didn't you can focus better or you have
better concentration i don't think most
people would say that's cheating right
that would just be hey you drink some
coffee before uh before the match uh but
are there
instances in chess or things that are
top of mind right now uh whether it's
adderall or other types of things that
people could be taking and ingesting to
actually give them an advantage in
playing
that's actually excellent question
because there was also a lot of debates
around that pretty much all the time and
uh and the answer is quite simple that
uh
actually there is no uh
kind of prohibited substances or
that there is nothing that uh is not
acceptable so it's not like uh
in uh athletics where uh
you see that you know they just summon
injections they're just not accepted
because it's a violation of laws and
then why they just would would come
after you in chess that there is no such
thing and if it's up to you you can
drink like 10 cups of coffee and uh
still it's it's not clear like first of
all why it happens because it's not
clear how it affects your your brain
uh
definitely we know that for example
coffee is a big stimulator right but at
the same time
it's not clear how it really helps to
perform uh over the board
and uh for some people it it really adds
up to their strengths for for some
others it might not and uh even
scientifically there is no
direct answer if uh
let's say eating something during the
game it would
boost your performance or not
that's why uh
like apart from uh
really using technologies and computer
cheating uh there is no such way to
cheat in any other way let's say by
drinking some some liquid
well we see that normally it's uh the
accepted kind of uh perception of that
that
it wouldn't help
yeah it's uh it's crazy to think about
um i've got a friend evo marinov who is
one of the top players in the world at
one minute fisher chess and when i told
him that i was going to speak with you
he sent me a quote from bobby fisher who
basically was talking about the
invention of fischer chess and for those
that don't know
it's basically the board starts out with
the pieces scattered in a random
formation and then if you play one
minute uh it obviously adds the pressure
of the time how do you think about some
of these other chess games that have
been invented over time either to cut
down on memorization or cut down on
specific advantages that people have um
is it something that you enjoy playing
do you just stick to kind of more
classical chess how do you think about
these games
today's episode is brought to you by ftx
us they're a safe regulated way to buy
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies they've got
very cheap fees sometimes as much as 85
cheaper than their competitors there's
also no minimum fees there's no
withdrawal fees or any other hidden fees
ultimately ftx us is trying to make it
dead simple for you to buy bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they also now have
digital stock trading as well with no
transaction fees and no payment for
order flow all you have to do is go
download the ftx app today from the app
store and use code pop and you'll get
some money back every single time you
trade 10 or more again go download the
ftx app today use code pomp and every
time you trade 10 or more they'll go
ahead and they'll give you some crypto
back the more you trade the more you
earn download the ftx app today
uh i personally myself will begin with
the second part i myself prefer the
classical chess
though i very much respect uh teacher
random chess i also enjoy playing it uh
though of course i don't play it as much
as classical game
but to add to that i would also say that
uh one minute bullet game it's also
completely different universe of chess
and uh
i i would say in general that i see that
we have uh
really different variations of chess and
uh playing like one minute online it's
in my understanding it's really not a
classical chess because i was uh raised
as a chess player
under completely different circumstances
when you have a chess position and uh
your goal is to uh
and find the best move find the best
plan and uh you're normally not
restricted in time so your goal is not
to to find the best move
in five seconds
and why i'm saying this because some
positions in shell they're
as difficult as for for you know finding
the solution you might need like at
least 15 minutes
and uh back in the old days uh
people trained uh
you know for some positions puzzles you
you might spend even hours
uh trying to find the solution and uh
that's really kind of also another way
to to enjoy chess when you really
literally spend hours and hours trying
to analyze one position
and trying to find the the solution and
you still cannot find it so it's like
you know uh
puzzles for mathematicians also they
in a way they're similar but uh with
different approaches so but back to
questions with uh with other types of
chess i
of course i i do respect the chess
evolves and
i uh do respect bullets as though i'm
not personally myself i'm not a fan of
it and the
one minute fish random uh frankly i
haven't seen it so i i i probably need
to you know spend some time to see
because i'm pretty sure it's amazing uh
since official random indeed since the
position is not trivial and you're
seeing it for the first time right from
the opening right from the beginning of
the game you need to uh
approach
it very differently and for that
you absolutely have
to have some some time on the clocks to
to just get get into position for
example personally for me it would take
definitely more than one minute just to
realize okay where the pieces are and
the
what would be the best setup of how to
begin the game but
hearing that people can play uh
an entire game in one minute with fisher
random it's it's really amazing but but
definitely it's
not another surprise for me and uh
i also appreciate uh seeing people do
this i i uh i refrain from ever playing
with him because i couldn't tell you
where the pieces are in one minute just
like you
so it is uh it is quite impressive uh
talk to me about the international chess
federation the obviously the elections
recently happened uh you were running
for president uh talk a little bit just
about that organization the current
leadership and why you had chosen to uh
to run
this decision to iran for myself it came
very unexpectedly uh this idea just came
to my mind uh around the end of april uh
around the time when uh the current
incumbent president archaivorca which
he declared that he wants to get
reelected and for me it was completely
insane and it still is
it's still terrible to see that
the current leadership of international
chess federation and uh
it's actually a long story and uh for
the background
uh actually that there were always
perception that uh chess is it's kind of
a soviet game
why it happened because apparently
soviet union was uh
dominating chef for many years uh
uh since like let's say in 1950s
and uh what happened was international
chess federation in 1995
uh we got elections where uh here's
another is the russian politician uh he
won the elections he is actually he was
not from the chess world okay he came
unexpectedly to kind of rescue the chess
world after the crisis that uh happened
after 13 years of presidency of uh
florence florencia campomanas who uh
uh arguably was uh was a kgb spy or
something like that was a kgb agent
actually and uh
for example gary kasparov who is
probably one of the most famous chess
player of our generation like many
generations actually uh he claimed that
uh
international chess organizations in a
way it's under control of kgb and it has
been like that at least since 1982 when
capomanes was first elected
so the story evolved that uh in 95 when
illumina
became the president
uh
he put some money in to see that his his
he's the businessman
and the way he kind of rescued
organization that's that's kind of also
the perception but
still there were a lot of scandals and
and
all kind of bad things and eventually it
turned out that illegitimate he has been
the president until 2018. for 23 years
we had the russian politician running
into the organization
he was actually famous for three things
one of them that he according to himself
he was abducted by aliens
which which is pretty cool to have uh
you know the main representative of the
chessboard who was abducted by aliens
then uh he was famous for his wizards
with uh meeting with
all the best people in our world like uh
muammar qaddafi saddam hussein bashar
al-assad
and those kind of things
and what i'm trying to say that
apparently the chess federation was not
was not about chess only which of course
is it's a huge shame so chess federation
for many years it was more about
politics and
it was an instrument of russian politics
for those years
and unfortunately it still is
and and finally in 2015 uh
illegitimate was
got sanctioned by u.s treasury for his
ties to syrian government and syrian ban
uh and uh eventually
he he actually tried to get reelected in
2018 and that was his intention and uh
what is really unfortunate about it that
the system is built in the way that it's
really almost impossible to beat the
incumbent president and however the
incumbent as it was in the case of
illegitimate he easily won all the
elections for example 2006 we had a
really great competition uh very uh
well-known uh chess organizer basil corp
from netherlands uh he competed with
illumina and of course all the chess
world and especially western chess world
we had high hopes that finally the
federation will become modern democratic
and uh and progressive
but but guess what illegitimate won just
easily back in the days then in 2014
gary casper of himself he ran against
illegitimate he put a lot of resources
and efforts to to become a president and
yet he lost uh also quite convincingly
simply because it's
really not possible to kind of beat this
corrupted system because whoever is the
president
uh you know illumina had all the
possibilities to travel around the world
and uh talk to delegates federations
eventually he had everything under
control so what happened in 2018 uh
archived vorkovic with a russian
politician with
um who has extremely prominent career in
kremlin he's been uh for many years uh
close eight close estate to putin
himself to dmitry medvedev when he was
uh president so volkovic he was deputy
prime minister for six years he was uh
advisor to the president also for many
years and you can imagine in 2018 the
guy who has little to do with chess
despite his father he was a
international chess are better but
that's the only connection that
duarkovic has to the chess world so the
guy just three months before the
elections he comes in and says like oh
yeah
i would like to run for peter presidency
and i would be good for the president
and uh at the same time imagine that he
withdraws from the elections he declares
full support to the workforce and why it
all happens just simply because
the worker which has enormous support of
russian government uh financial support
political support and all kind of those
things and uh
eventually brokerage won those elections
in 2018.
and uh
now 2022 uh the elections that we had
just
one month ago
in april i just realized that this time
we're just on the edge of not having
elections at all because really nobody
wants to contest this because also many
people just understand that you just
hope
you cannot
beat such machine especially when again
the federation is fully under political
control of russia
uh
moreover of course
what added spices to that that uh
dissertation is completely different
from what it was in 2018 or
2006 2014 uh
when
again we were talking about chess but
now
uh we're uh probably not the only one i
think in in boxing it's it's
in a way it's a similar situation in
boxing federation that
we're a sports federation that is run by
uh by a russian politician
and of course it's it's not only a big
shame for for us as chess players it's
just
to have such representation uh but also
from the practical point of view it's uh
quite uh difficult to attract any
sponsors
so if we say that
the international chess federation the
main goal of it is to globally promote
chess
how on ours we can do that if if no
sponsors would like to
to sign any contracts merely because
they know that for themselves being in
any way associated with russian politics
and now we see what what russian
politics actually means it's
not only terror inside the country now
they're just bringing terror outside of
their country for uh actually many years
and this full-scale invasion in ukraine
is just
which happened in february it's just
another round of this
external aggression of russia and and
from practical point of view for us as a
chess world to
have worker which requests close ties to
kremlin and say that and pretend that
nothing happens and we still can
uh can talk about chess not about
politics uh
it was quite
i mean
difficult to even think of that and
that's why i did draw my decision to
to enter the competition myself and say
like okay hey if nobody in the world
really wants to to say the right things
and
you know compete against this system
then i would do this and uh
that's how i ended up in this elections
and
i'm really you know
proud of
my efforts and i'm really happy that
you know so many people they landed
support because also what happens in the
chess world
many understand that things are not
going the right way
though
not many are willing to do anything
because they they just see that it's
it's hopeless so we just got used to to
being around by russian politicians and
it's been for 23 years with illumino and
now it's after four years of work which
we were saying like okay okay we have
like another four years of russian
politicians being in the office and uh
we pretend that nothing happened
which is of course
i mean at least disappointing if to say
that yeah one of the things that makes
this an even more i think kind of
sensitive topic for you is you obviously
are ukrainian uh and uh russia's
invasion of ukraine uh while not
directly related to anything in the
chess world you're bringing up a number
of things where uh it may not be as
black and white as is it related is it
not um how do you think about the
russian invasion of ukraine and and as
you speak to people in ukraine who i'm
assuming you still have family and
friends there what are they telling you
about the actual situation on the ground
well it's it's also it's a very large
topic and of course uh i i do have a lot
of relatives their friends pretty much
all my life
in ukraine and uh though i live in us
for the past uh
seven years uh still
i'm very much ukrainian and
it's it's
just to say it's heartbreaking for me to
see what happens it's just
just the least i can say
of course i'm very much outraged it's
it's
really not
kind of
imaginable to see that in 21st century
uh
one country just can't declare that
another one doesn't exist and
it's kind of our artificial
uh
kind of nation or something somebody
this nonsense that putin tries to and
russian propaganda tries to put
in justification of what they do uh
it's it's really
you know shocking to see and i think uh
my feelings the uh
of course they they're more sensitive
and uh
uh of course i see things differently
but
but at least i i
how to say uh
well to me it's good to see that we have
a lot of support it's it's it's really
uh
amazing to see that we are not there by
ourselves in this battle i see that
literally all the same people in the
world they understand that it's not
right
uh really we would prefer to talk about
chess about you know
i don't know politics sports uh
finances
economics culture those kind of things
but not talking about war and
you know suffering of people
and and what russia actually
does this day is
just a complete horror because
it's really difficult to to put other
things out of context including chess as
well and of course uh i i
i do not kind of uh hide this that my
biggest motivation to run for peter
presidency it was also driven by the
fact that
i just couldn't stand the idea that
we're still okay to have russian
politicians and we're still okay to
pretend that nothing happens
uh
because really we see that
you know why russia needs it
why uh
it's important for them to to be part of
the civilized world to say like okay hey
guys
we're in the in the chess we're in
culture and politics we're we're like
having some negotiations talks we play
sports but at the same time we can
freely invade other countries and uh
make just really terroristic attacks for
no reason and that's what russia keeps
on doing all this uh six months
of this invasion they they're not uh
doing like as they claim that it's a
special military operation against some
nazis it's just all complete nonsense
what they do they just target civilian
objects so many people are dying for no
reason
including actually russian soldiers
and
it seems that
for russians it's acceptable they say
like oh okay yeah we just keep on you
know
thinking of other things like you know
playing chess or something
uh so yeah but just getting back to your
question of course
all what happens it's it's a huge shock
and uh
of course on the personal level for me
uh definitely and uh and i i i wouldn't
exaggerate if i say that it's a big
shock for the entire world
because now we all see and witness uh
how indeed cruel and how bad this
alternator and regime in russia is
because prior to that it was all kind of
hidden
though it's
like on my personal view it it happened
not in february it actually happened
long time ago pretty much when when
putin came into power in in 2000 in the
beginning of 2000s
uh because we know of invasion of
georgian 2008 annexation of crimea in
2014
also we know all those spy operations
and all those scandals when uh
russian intelligence assassinate people
around the world like in london and
berlin in in doha dubai like also
interference in u.s elections
and the world seems to be okay with that
they say like oh yeah i mean that's
really bad but it's politics we just
keep it aside
uh but now now the world is indeed
shocked to see that
another round of this aggression against
humanity it happens in ukraine when
russia declares so
yeah we just
you know pursue our
some interests and uh
yeah we
we have the right to do what we do
which is
i mean it's really abnormal and uh
and again i i'll probably repeat myself
on that that it's it's really uh her
heart warming to see that we have a lot
of support and
ukrainians really appreciate
the help of western countries the united
states european union
which actually
and many other countries that are united
against this idea that we can
let it go and say like okay hey uh
russia's
is still big country we're still you
know afraid of them and let them do
whatever they like with their neighbors
what's up with the uh president
zielinski like i think most people in
the us they never heard of him before
and uh just this past week he was uh
literally ringing the bell to the u.s
stock market he was on uh national
financial television he's been on the
cover of vogue magazine he's obviously
spoke directly to
congress and and uh he's an individual
who obviously as the leader of ukraine
uh was on the international stage right
to some degree but given the uh the
situation and the conflict here uh he
has now risen to a level of
international prominence that i think
many people have been surprised by what
do ukrainians kind of think about uh the
role that he's taken in all this
uh
yeah i would say also like normally i
don't like generalizations because you
know ukrainians are also very different
and uh
it's difficult to say like okay hey like
all ukraines they they think the same
and of course we still even amid war we
have uh
some people who who appreciate his
actions or some of his actions and so on
but of course in general uh
here probably i would generalize yes
ukrainians are very proud of zilensky
and including myself
uh i i wasn't fantastic when he became a
president in 2019 and also for the
background he is a comedian actor so
he's not a professional politician and
uh
and never been into politics but he's a
very famous in ukraine he was and uh
and that that really helped him to to
become a president because people in
ukraine they were also disappointed with
probably previous garments but anyway to
your question
indeed he became uh
to some extent a national hero because
he uh
refused to
to flee from key which is uh
uh
just
i mean
just the best decision ever i would say
uh and of course i i praise him for that
for his courage
uh for his uh
also bravery and uh all the actions he
does and of course uh amid war uh i
personally i i i lent all my full
support to what he does and i really
admire what what he does and uh his uh
uh all efforts to raise awareness to uh
increase help to solicit help from from
other countries it's it's really what
what we need and uh what what we hope
for and uh ukraine is really united uh
uh for our leader and uh even if we talk
about political leader of course
ukrainians uh they're very much united
in their support to army forces we
donate a lot of money uh from all over
the world
also it's really uh amazing to see and
for me personally i witnessed it that
humanitarian aid and support
have been slowing into ukraine for those
past six months
just millions of tons of
faith and even here in los angeles where
i'm based
we don't have a big deal for our
ukrainians but we're still very much
united in our support to ukraine and we
do all we can and
in various ways and uh what zelensky
does appeal into global communities it's
one of the ways to to
help the
our case and uh finally stop russian
aggression and push all the occupants
from ukraine
yeah it is uh it's pretty incredible to
see uh how quickly he's been able to uh
to get that message out and obviously uh
most of the people in ukraine that i've
uh spoken to that either lived there
before i still have family and friends
there uh or live somewhere abroad seem
to be pretty appreciative of uh of his
efforts talk to me about uh kind of the
market the financial market you have a
phd uh in applied economics and uh uh
chess obviously is something that you're
very well known for but you kind of have
this whole other life and have a ton of
kind of traditional education but also i
know a lot of interest how do you see
kind of the macro environment right now
uh and then maybe more specifically for
this audience a lot of people care about
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies and do you
have any thoughts there
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep good sleep is a game changer and
the eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine i sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod three you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
innate sleep you can go to hsleep.com
pomp today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order
eightsleep.com not only do i sleep on it
every night it literally changed my life
and i begged the founders to let me
invest in the company
eightsleep.com go get yourself an
eight-sleep pod and get a better night
of sleep
uh yeah i will probably also break your
question into parts uh
uh of course especially
the topic of uh
russian aggression in ukraine it it's
also pretty pretty much obvious i guess
to the audience that world economy is
shaken because of that
and uh
simply because russia is
quite a big country though not
not that much large economy
ukraine is also one of the biggest
suppliers of agricultural
foods of agricultural markets apparently
they're shaken and we see that the
stability of the entire world uh
economies
is under a threat um well maybe it's a
little exaggerated but definitely we see
that uh
uh
there are a huge fluctuation
for example
you can see it on a gas station right so
gas prices over the past months as they
they were
uh
fluctuating pretty badly and uh we've
seen that uh the
the increase in gas prices were
unprecedented uh
in the times and of course uh
prices for for energy sources they did
they're they're one of the biggest
drivers of
the global economy
and uh
until the this war is is over until we
stop putting uh
it's still gonna be shaken
difficult to get back to the stability
because uh
again the modern world uh has changed
and now we see that it became truly more
global some people they might think like
hey it's kind of a regional war that
we're really far from it and why would
we care about it but in fact we see that
there are so many interconnections uh so
many global companies that operate in uh
different continents that really the
economy uh became global and uh in this
sense we have like are like what 8
billion people but still we are very
much interconnected by any uh
such things and that's why
we see that uh
the
those
shakeups of economy they
they're driven by this war
and uh and you see like many brands they
exited
russia of course
the investment environment in ukraine is
really in a poor situation because of
because of the war
uh so that's why it's really difficult
to predict what happened because the
station still is not stabilized uh
uh go going back to your uh part of of
uh
cryptocurrency and financial market
uh
also for me i i would also put a
disclaimer there that i'm not a big
expert so the way i i do have a phd in
economics it still uh doesn't make me
a big expert in the field though though
i would say that also financial markets
and that's my personal view they're
still very much driven by the real
economy
and then again it's it's it's really
very much related to the first part of
question that with those global shakes
in in the economy with disruptions of
many supply chains uh
on many goods we'll see that uh the
restructuring of
economies
it would take time
and uh
and i really hope that uh the war will
be over and uh
ukraine will get victory soon and then
we will be talking about new reality and
sense that uh
uh
in a stable environment how we gonna be
building up uh not only like political
relationships and those kind of things
but also how to uh
rebuild those supply chains and how
they're going to be reflected for uh for
the economy
uh i would just make a just a humble
prediction that
you know once we go over those uh
uh
kind of uh shots that we see uh
the economy will be
kind of rebuilding pretty quickly and uh
of course i'm not talking about ukraine
but
pretty much the entire world so once the
energy prices are stabilized uh
we can kind of you know slowly progress
uh to
kind of a more stable environment i
would say in this way and uh
okay if we go back to cryptocurrencies
um
also it's quite a big topic uh
i would just say that it's uh
to my point of view uh
in a way it's a niche market and uh
it will be this way for for quite some
time and uh
i'm not really sure that it can become
uh
more global in terms of uh
presence in financial market
yeah it feels like a lot of folks who
are into uh technology obviously are
into bitcoin cryptocurrencies uh but
also there's uh some interesting parts
of our conversation today uh russia
ukraine obviously lots of people talking
about uh bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
along with other technologies if you
think of the chess world there's
actually been a number of people in the
chess world who are very interested in
in these assets as well and so i tend to
think uh a lot about how uh usually a
financial asset i don't take real estate
as an example it ends up being somewhat
isolated you're a real estate investor
or you're not a real estate investor
it's in your portfolio or it's not but
you don't think about like i like real
estate and therefore i also like you
know chess and this and this and this uh
but in some way uh kind of bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies it does seem to attract
a a certain type of
audience that is receptive to it early
right so maybe that's like an early
adopter type thing maybe it's people who
like uh math and science and technology
there's a lot of different ways you
could cut it but it is fascinating to
see how quickly and you know 13 years or
so uh an asset that you know literally
didn't exist now all of a sudden has
this global brand that uh regardless of
the language when people see that you
know orange uh b they know what it is
and and uh it's something i'm fascinated
by i don't think we fully understand yet
you know kind of how this has happened
and where it's going um but but it
definitely is different than i think
anything that you and i have seen in our
lifetimes
yeah i i absolutely agree with that and
uh yeah i also like your notion that
indeed it's it's kind of bubbles right
uh
and i think like the the direct
comparison is uh probably social media
and
and also what happens uh like in uh
like information information-wise right
so we really uh
we again we kind of think that we we see
the global picture in fact uh
that's
not really true because many people
indeed they see the part of it depending
on their bubble and as you say like for
example if you're a real estate investor
then uh yeah you you you have some
expertise in that but but if you're not
then uh you just have no idea what goes
on there right so uh for example just
talking about real estate here in uh in
california where i live now for
just slightly over than one year i'm i'm
amazed to see that uh
the the real estate prices they they
they keep on rising that's that's really
interesting since many people who are
not not really uh
you know experts on that they say that
hey
it's a bubble it's it's not possible to
see that you know prices they've been
rising for more than 20 years and and
now even i made this pandemic when
many people actually they
leave california right because
technologies also allow us to to work
remotely uh still we see that real
estate prices for some reason they they
keep on rising
even more
so
that's why yeah it's it's indeed
[Music]
many questions to that uh what kind of
bubble we're focusing on yeah it's
absolutely fascinating um when when i
think about uh you and you have so many
different interests how do you describe
yourself to people do you tell people uh
i play chess i'm a grandmaster do you
tell them no i'm into economics is it
just i have multi-uh kind of faceted
interests like how do you think about
your own identity
it's it's quite combined you know i i
like uh in chess world i'll like refer
to myself as a semi-professional chess
player because obviously when people
hear that i'm a grandmaster they they
think like wow apparently the guy spent
all his life in chess
which is uh which is not really true and
i'm really
you know thankful to chess that it
allows not only focus on the chess board
and just what but also
not compromising with with your chess
career it allows you to do some other
things
i've spent a lot of time in education
and of course doing my phd it took me
six years to
to accomplish this
milestone
so referring to myself it's
difficult to say hey probably i would
just quote my mother who
likes to say that life it's it's just
multitasking on various levels
and then you need to be uh
you know
a good family member you need to be a
good professional in what you do you
need to you know like your hobbies and
so on so uh
i i would say yeah i'm very much as
player of course though i i don't play
chess professionally and i i don't coach
uh professionally though still i yeah
i'm very much proud of my chess career
and uh
i'm a little chess player and
uh and of course at the same time i i'm
an economist uh
and uh professionally that that's what i
do uh mostly economics
i love it
i love it uh i want two recommendations
from you the first is on uh chess
literature uh is there one book or one
piece of information that if somebody is
like hey i want to get more serious
about chess that you would highly
suggest they go and uh and read
also tough question because
i guess you know it's in any other field
that there is no unique uh
advice there there is not something that
you say hey like just just read one book
and you will become an expert
you know such book doesn't exist but
though i for for the beginners those who
uh just began playing cheers who played
just just a little i normally like
suggesting a book of by uh
blanca who is uh
who used to be a world champion uh
as far as i remember first were not
third world champion
uh so he he wrote a book uh which is
called like um
yeah i i'm trying to recall the name but
it's pretty much the the book for
beginners it's called like you know
self-taught manual for uh
for chess players and why i like it
because it it really has uh
uh
the different steps
how you how you understand the game so
let's say if you're a beginner you can
just open the book on the first pages
and it explains you you know how pieces
how they move then uh
later parts of the book they explain
very well the the basic concepts uh
well what means center and chess how to
develop pieces uh what plans are more
effective than the others but of course
this is the book for for the beginners
uh for people who were more or less
advanced players
uh
the approach would be completely
different and to that i would say uh
uh
general suggestion is just to read
literature as much as you can i mean
chess literature and and of course
play the game because
that's ultimately what drives people to
like the game not only you know studying
but also play and enjoy because after
all uh chess just as a game it's it's
not only science not only uh way to or
like let's say uh
way to self-improve it's it's also a
game that you you enjoy
that's awesome uh and then the second
piece of uh recommendation if you will
if people want to learn more about
what's going on in ukraine is there one
place that you would send them to uh uh
to kind of learn more so that it's not
just from the american media or
international media like is there a
source that you go to to check
uh that's actually excellent question
and i myself
i'm maybe lucky in this sense because i
you know i i have access to
various information of course i i do
read and follow closely ukrainian
sources i
uh read like official statements
journalists as well as
uh since i know russian uh yeah i've
been following uh russian news for for
many years and i know russian propaganda
and i've been witnessing how different
the reality is and you can imagine that
you know being in ukraine and the seeing
like what how ukraine portrayed the some
you know some occasions or some things
that happened
seeing like what western media say about
it and seeing how russian propaganda
portrays it then you're you're amazed
wow like it's it's just complete
difference you see like for example
again you have like a white pawn
right on the chessboard and you know
that it is a white pawn
but then you see that the the
perspective of how people see this white
pawn it's very different
and that's why it's it's uh
for me personally it's really
uh
what to say uh shocking to see
indeed how far this propaganda in russia
how effective it is because once you are
told that this white pawn is a black
queen
and everybody tells it to you from from
every
tv channel you you switch then you begin
believing it and then you just don't
have any critical thinking so my general
advice would be just not to focus on one
source but to
to see various sources and frankly i've
been seeing it
here in us as well that people they just
focus on like hey we're watching let's
say fox news or we are watching cnn but
my approach and my suggestion would be
no you you guys better watch both of
them then you watch other experts then
you watch something else then definitely
you need to listen to people who are uh
for producing those news let's put it
this way so to hear what they say and
what they think and ultimately you just
make your decision on your own who you
believe and what makes more sense to you
and so on that that's actually how you
improve in chill because again if you
will switch back to the chess topic uh
you can read one book and it will tell
you that okay this is the good opening
then you open another book and it will
tell you like oh that's a complete
nonsense then once you turn on your
chess engine it will say completely
different story but ultimately what
makes you a professional what makes you
to understand things it's your critical
thinking what you believe in and uh what
you see when you look at the board
uh
in terms of how to perceive the what
happens in ukraine
you you my suggestion would be to not
limit yourself to one source
uh
and uh just just check as much as
possible if you have access to
uh
international media if you you know
other languages that that's that's
really helpful so just check what people
say also be very critical to that that's
also very important because we see that
uh
and i've been facing it a lot that you
know some people they they really trust
whatever they they're told
and uh
of course
it's been the case for for all the times
of history i guess that
you know the lies can be everywhere
it doesn't mean you need to to trust
whatever the first source you
you hear
uh
definitely be very critical because you
would be amazed when you see russian
propaganda you see the world completely
different
and he was like wow i mean
maybe maybe that that makes sense or
maybe it doesn't then you begin also
questioning yourself and that's why i'm
saying that you know limiting yourself
to one source it's it's quite dangerous
because
then you
uh
you you might begin questioning some
things like you know like a white pawn
right you can say like well maybe i'm
wrong maybe indeed it's not a white pawn
it's something else or something like
that so
yeah that's that's again it's a very
general advice but it's it's i think
it's very much needed so just just
remember that you shouldn't focus you
shouldn't limit yourself to one source
i i love that that's the way you answer
the question because i always say that
there's a critical thinking crisis
underway uh globally and uh the ability
to consume lots of information from
different sources and then kind of
synthesize it and think through it as a
important skill and probably one that uh
we we should develop much better and and
young people
around the world um i've really enjoyed
speaking with you uh today and i think
you're so fascinating in terms of all of
your different interests and and the
level of success that you've achieved if
people want to follow up with you or
they want to ask for their questions or
follow your uh chess career as it
continues um where should we send them
is twitter or is there some other place
that you think is best to send people
twitter is completely fine also i would
suggest uh checking my
video website campaign which is
fightforce.com
though it's not very active apparently
after the elections but still uh there
is a lot of information on on myself on
on the team that i
uh managed to build up in just you know
a few months of this campaign and i'm
extremely proud
and humbled to see so many experts uh
being by my side because we share the
democratic values and everything so uh
yeah twitter is perfectly final though
i'm more active on facebook
where you can also find me by my first
and last name uh
i also prefer that what are they doing
in chess as well i prefer to use my real
name uh not like you know some
as in chess we
have a joke like it's like you know you
play some
pepperoni cheese or something some some
nonsense uh apparently that you play a
nickname instead of playing a real guy
so yeah facebook twitter again
fightforce.com those are perfect sources
to reach out to me i love it chess and
uh in the bitcoin world plenty of uh
pseudonymous names that uh make you
laugh is uh is one definite similarity
awesome well listen thank you so much
for your time today i really enjoyed it
uh and i think people will get an
absolute uh a lot of learning and also a
lot of interest uh kind of out of your
experience and and our conversation
today so thank you
yeah thank you so much for having me